M
AND "CNN TONIGHT".
>> Announcer: THIS IS CNN
BREAKING NEWS.
>>> GOOD EVENING, I'M ALISYN
CAMEROTA.
BARBARA WALTERS, NEWS ANCHOR,
REPORTER, TALK SHOW HOST,
TELEVISION LEGEND, SHE'S PASSED
AWAY AT THE AGE OF 93.
SHE HAD A STELLAR CAREER.
SHE JOINED ABC NEWS IN 1976
BECOMING THE FIRST FEMALE ANCHOR
OF A TV NEWS PROGRAM AND THREE
YEARS LATER BECAME CO-HOST OF
"20/20" AND LAUNCHED "THE VIEW"
THAT'S STILL ON THE AIR.
IN A STATEMENT BARBARA WALTERS
SPOKESPERSON CONFIRMED THE NEWS
ANCHOR'S DEATH.
QUOTE, BARBARA WALTERS PASSED
AWAY PEACEFULLY IN HER HOME
SURROUNDED BY LOVED ONES.
SHE LIVED HER LIFE WITH IN
REGRETS.
SHE WAS A TRAILBLAZER NOT ONLY
FOR FEMALE JOURNALISTS BUT ALL
WOMEN.
THAT'S WHAT THE STATEMENT SAID.
WE HAVE SO MUCH TO TALK ABOUT
WITH BARBARA WALTERS AND HOW SHE
IMPACTED ALL OF US JOURNALISTS.
JOINING ME IS JOHN MILLER, HE
CO-ANCHORED "20/20" WITH BARBARA
WALTERS.
SAD NEWS.
SHE WAS 93.
SHE LIVED A LIFE BUT SHE --
ANYONE WHO IS I'D SAY 40 OR
ABOVE WHOSE GONE INTO JOURNALISM
DID IT ON THE SHOULDERS OF
BARBARA WALTERS IN SOMEWAY.
>> WELL, THAT'S TRUE.
I MEAN, BARBARA WALTERS DIDN'T
JUST BREAK THE GLASS CEILING.
SHE CAUSED THE COLLAPSE OF THE
GLASS BUILDING AND DID IT ONE
STEP AT A TIME THROUGH HER
CAREER.
REMEMBER, SHE WAS ON THE "TODAY
SHOW" AND THEN MOVED TO ABC
WHERE SHE WAS CO-ANCHOR AND SOME
BECAME TO RECENT HER PRESENCE SO
MUCH ON THE AIR, THERE JUST
WASN'T CHEMISTRY, HE WAS ALMOST
HOSTILE AND SHE MOVED OFF AND
FORGED HER OWN PATH GETTING THE
INTERVIEWS THAT OTHER PEOPLE
COULDN'T GET BECOMING THE GO-TO
PERSON WHETHER YOU WERE A SUPER
STAR OR A VILLAIN AND SHE WAS
VERY GENEROUS.
WHEN HER PARTNER ON "20/20" A
MAGAZINE SHOW SHE PIONEERED,
WHEN HER PARTNER HOUGH DOWNS
RETIRED, SHE CALLED ME IN AND
SAID I WANT YOU TO BE MY IN
CO-ANCHOR AND I REMEMBER
SAYING -- AND THIS IS ABOUT
GENEROSITY AND HER CONFIDENCE IN
HER OWN PICKS.
I REMEMBER SAYING BARBARA, I'VE
NEVER ANCHORED ANYTHING AT ALL
IN TELEVISION AND THIS IS ONE OF
THE HIGHEST RATED TELEVISION
NEWS SHOWS IN HISTORY.
SHE SAID WELL, DON'T WORRY.
EVERYBODY HAS TO START
SOMEWHERE.
>> THAT'S WONDERFUL.
THAT'S A GREAT STORY.
SHE FACED RESENTMENT FROM A LOT
OF MALE CO-ANCHORS.
INCREDIBLE INTERVIEWS, SO MANY
WERE RECORD RATINGS BREAKING AND
MEMBERBLE.
SO JUST TO NAME A FEW OBVIOUSLY
SHE DID A LOT OF HEADS OF STATE
AND SHE SAT DOWN WITH MICHAEL
JACKSON, WHICH, YOU KNOW,
BASICALLY BROKE THE RATING
SYSTEM AND THEN I THINK THE
HIGHEST RATED ONE EVER WAS
MONICA LEWINSKY.
AS YOU SAY, JOHN, PEOPLE WHETHER
IN THE MIDDLE OF A SCANDAL OR IT
WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
CELEBRATION, SHE WAS THEIR
GO-TO.
SHE WAS THE PERSON THAT
ESTABLISHED HERSELF.
YOU JUST HADN'T MADE IT UNTIL
YOU SAT DOWN AND CRIED THROUGH A
BARBARA WALTERS INTERVIEW.
>> WELL, A LOT OF THIS WAS ABOUT
HER SPECIAL TECHNIQUE THAT SHE
FORCED.
IF YOU WERE BEING INTERVIEWED BY
MIKE WALLACE ON "60 MINUTE" WHEN
THE KILLER QUESTION CAME, IT
CAME IN THE FORM OF A KILLER KI
STILETTO.
SHE WOULD ASK ANYTHING THAT
NEEDED TO BE ASKED.
SHE DIDN'T DO IT WITH A STA LET
TOE BUT A SCAPLE.
IT WAS A HOSTILE INTERVIEWER
SEEM LIKE THE SHE GOT A LOT OUT
OF A LOT OF PEOPLE.
YOU NAME IT, WORLD LEADERS,
FIDEL CASTRO, SHE BROUGHT ME
BACK THE BOX OF CIGARS BECAUSE
SHE WAS NOT A CIGAR SMOKER AND
SHE KNEW THAT WOULD MAKE ME
HAPPY.
IT WAS THE WAY THAT MADE PEOPLE
FEEL CONFIDENT AND GET THEY ARE
STORY OUT.
>> STAND BY IF YOU WOULD.
WE HAVE LISA LING ON THE PHONE.
SHE WAS A "VIEW" CO-HOST FOR
YEARS.
LISA, TELL US WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS
ARE TONIGHT WITH THIS SAD NEWS.
>> I'M SO DEVASTATED TO LEARN OF
BARBARA'S PASSING.
I HADN'T TALKED TO HER IN AWHILE
SO I'VE BEEN CONCERNED ABOUT HER
HEALTH AND HOW SHE'S BEEN DOING
BUT I -- THIS WOMAN PAVED THE
WAY FOR ALL OF US.
I DON'T KNOW I WOULD BE DOING
WHAT I'D BEEN DOING HAD SHE NOT
BEEN THERE FIRST AND LITERALLY
FOUGHT HER WAY TO THE TOP AND I
HAVE ALWAYS HAD SO MUCH RESPECK
FOR HER AND IT WAS SUCH A
TREMENDOUS HONOR TO SIT
ALONGSIDE HER FOR THREE YEARS AT
THE "VIEW."
>> YEAH, I FEEL THE SAME WAY.
YOU KNOW, WE ALL HAVE -- ALL OF
US FEMALE JOURNALISTS HAVE SOME
SORT OF ORIGIN STORY THAT
INVOLVES BARBARA WALTERS.
MINE HAPPENED IN UTERO.
MY MOTHER CLAIMS SHE WAS
WATCHING BARBARA WALTERS WHEN
SHE WAS PREGNANT WITH ME AND
THOUGHT THAT WOULD BE AN
INTERESTING JOB FOR MY DAUGHTER.
I MEAN, IT GOES TO SHOW HOW LONG
BARBARA WALTERS WAS IN OUR LIVES
AND AN INFLUENTIAL PRESENCE AND
TRAILBLAZER.
TO REMIND EVERYBODY, SHE STARTED
IN 1961 AS A REPORTER, WRITER
AND PANEL MEMBER AT NBC BUT IT
WAS NO EASY ROAD AS YOU KNOW,
LISA.
THE ASSIGNMENTS THAT SHE GOT AND
WHAT SHE HAD TO ENDURE AND
BREAKTHROUGH IN ORDER TO BECOME
BARBARA WALTERS, FOR YEARS, THEY
ONLY GAVE HER THE FASHION BEAT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> HER TENACITY ALLOWED HER TO
BECOME THIS ICON.
>> ONE THING I WANT TO SHARE,
WHEN I STARTED AT THE "VIEW" I
WAS IN MY 20s.
I WAS STILL A CUB REPORTER AND I
WAS SO -- ALWAYS TRYING TO
PEPPER HER WITH QUESTIONS AND
ASK HER ABOUT HOW SHE GOT THAT
INTERVIEW WITH FIDEL CASTRO AND
SO ON.
SHE WOULD ALWAYS SAY TO ME, SHE
WOULD LOOK ME IN THE EYES AND
SAY LISA, NO MATTER WHAT, ITIOU
ANYTHING STICKS WITH YOU, LET IT
BE NEVER NEGLECT YOUR PERSONAL
LIFE.
SHE WAS EMPHATIC ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE SHE HAD TO MAKE SO MANY
SACRIFICES TO GET TO WHERE SHE
WAS AND I HAVE NEVER FORGOTTEN
ABOUT THAT AND I CERTAINLY --
I'VE THOUGHT ABOUT WHAT SHE SAID
TO ME SO MANY TIMES AS I'VE
TRIED TO NAVIGATE THIS BUSINESS
THAT I NEVER WANTED TO HAVE TO
MAKE THOSE SACRIFICES AND I
DIDN'T BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE
BARBARA DID IT FOR US IN SO MANY
WAYS.
>> I TOTALLY AGREE.
I'M SO GLAD YOU SAID THAT, LISA.
I KNOW THAT TO BE TRUE, ALSO.
WOMEN WHO GOT INTO THIS BUSINESS
IN THE '70s AND '80s HAD TO GIVE
UP A LOT IN THEIR PERSONAL
LIVES.
MANY OF THEM DIDN'T HAVE
CHILDREN.
SHE HAD, I BELIEVE, THREE
DIVORCES.
IT WAS -- YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW
HARD IT WAS TO HAVE A PERSONAL
LIFE WHEN YOU WERE TRAVELING AND
INTERVIEWING HEADS OF STATE AND
ALL THE COMPETITION AND SHARP
ELBOWS SHE HAD TO ENDURE.
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT UP
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THAT WAS A
SACRIFICE SHE WISHED SHE DIDN'T
HAVE TO MAKE BUT SHE WAS A
PRODUCT OF HER TIME.
>> SHE SAID THAT WHEN SHE WAS
RETIRING FROM "THE VIEW" AND
ABC.
SHE SAID HER BIGGEST REGRET IS
SHE DIDN'T SPEND AS MUCH TIME AS
SHE SHOULD HAVE SPENT WITH HER
DAUGHTER JACKIE WHOM I CAN TELL
YOU SHE LOVED MORE THAN ANYTHING
UNTIL THE WORLD.
>> THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
LISA, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HOLD ON FOR A SECOND BECAUSE WE
WANT TO BRING IN SHARON WAXMAN
NOW WHO HAS HER OWN OBVIOUSLY
STORY.
SHE'S A FOUNDER AND EDITOR IN
CHIEF OF THE WRAP.COM.
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING TONIGHT?
>> SHE WAS A PRESENCE THROUGH
OUR LIVES.
YOU MADE THE POINT SHE STARTED
IN 1960 AND RETIRED I GUESS IN
THE MID 2015 OF THERE ABILITIES.
-- THERE ABOUTS.
SHE NEVER WENT AWAY AS A
PRESENCE.
AS A CONSTANT SYMBOL OF
INTEGRITY, SYMBOL OF CAREER AND
AMBITION AND INTELLIGENCE THAT
YOU COULD ASPIRE TO SO I THINK
THAT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT AND
WHEN I THINK ABOUT ALL OF THE
TARNISH THAT WE HAVE ON SO MANY
OF OUR LEGENDARY FIGURES IN
MEDIA BAR -- BARBARA WALTERS, IT
CAME CYCLE AFTER CYCLE OF THE
VARIOUS PERMUTATIONS OF HER
CAREER WHETHER "THE TODAY SHOW"
OR THE ABC EVENING NEWS CAST OR
STARTING "THE VIEW" OR DOING ONE
ON ONES WITH PRESIDENTS.
SHE WAS A SYMBOL OF WHAT
JOURNALISM OUGHT TO BE.
AT LEAST THAT'S HOW IT WAS FOR
ME.
>> YOU TALK ABOUT HER INTERVIEWS
WITH PRESIDENTS.
SHE INTERVIEWED EVERY U.S.
PRESIDENT AND FIRST LADY.
YOU'RE RIGHT, YOU DIDN'T HAVE A
CHOICE.
ALL ROADS TO THE WHITE HOUSE LED
THROUGH BARBARA WALTERS.
>> EXACT